hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well in letter 63 senica is seemingly
consoling his friend lilius on a common
event back in Roman times and also
unfortunately and inevitably in our own
the loss of a friend through death which
is bound to happen to all of us unless
we're extraordinarily lucky and we die
before all of our friends but he's not
just consoling him he's actually
providing him with some very useful and
I think
well-grounded realistic advice so he
begins by saying that you know I am
sorry your friend has passed away I want
you not to grieve excessively and so we
should talk about this term grieving
which is a perfectly fine
translation of doar which is a broader
sense of feeling pain so grief is a kind
of pain that we feel when we have
suffered a loss part particularly a loss
of somebody to whom we are attached who
we feel as part of our life and notice
the key term here senica is not saying
I'm not going to tell you to grieve at
all as a matter of fact he'll even bring
up towards the end of the letter his own
example of grieving for his beloved
anaus serenus and he actually says I I
did that excessively myself so I
understand this he says I don't want you
to to grieve PL IO more than is the
right amount more than it is you know
proportionate right and he tells us
something really quite extraordinary
here so senica is a stoic he's
definitely a member of the stoic school
and a lot of people think that stoicism
means you don't show any emotion ideally
you know you stuff them down deep inside
or even better you don't feel them at
all don't get attached to people that is
not genuine stoicism and senica talks
here he may be referencing the legendary
Sage the perfect person the ideal of
stoicism or he might be just talking
about people who are very very
welldeveloped in it he says such
firmness of mind so is not to grieve at
all belongs only to the person who has
risen high above
Misfortune now this Rising high this is
actually from a stoic perspective that I
think really a perspective more broadly
of ancient philosophy this is what we
call Great sness or magnam minity which
is part of the virtue of courage or
fortitude for the stoics and it's
something that you know if you've
developed yourself enough you're able to
you know rise above they always use a
metaphor of height in this case notice
what he says about this
person they will feel a
twinge right so um vit they will feel
something they won't be
completely sealed off not feeling
anything totally unaffected they'll feel
a twinge but it's just a twinge what
about the rest of us he says we may
forgiven our tears if there are not too
many so it's a matter not of whether you
cry at all but how much you cry and why
you're crying and and the conditions
under that and he says if we do regain
control having lost a friend now notice
what he goes on here he's not just
saying ah you know cry if you have to
because you're weak or something like
that having lost a friend you should not
be dry eyed
but neither should you drown in Weeping
and he's got this really great phrase
here um you should cry but not whail so
laum EST right it is fitting for you to
cry to have lacri tears but don't wail
don't go overboard so you know think
about people at funerals where they lose
themselves in grief and they're staring
at their clothes or the the the coffin
is going into the ground and instead of
just like putting a a rose on it or a
stone or whatever it's going to be they
jump onto the coffin okay that's going
way way too far right they're constantly
talking about the great loss that
they've suffered and so senica says okay
let's let's think about this with a lot
of people now he's not saying this is a
completely blanket statement about grief
but for a lot of people why do they have
have Lamentations and the English word
there is actually just a cognant of
lament in
Latin well he says that there's a bit of
other centeredness in this it's not just
you feeling your own grief by yourself
you're kind of putting on a
show perhaps for actual others in front
of you perhaps for those who you have
internalized he says what is the source
of weeping beyond measure we are trying
by our tears to prove our sense of loss
it's not that grief forces us but we are
exhibiting grief to others and this is a
great Insight there's a lot of people
who you know when you say ah you know
you don't have to like go overboard with
your grief they're like well how can I
show how important this person was to me
well the person who was important is
dead so they're not looking at you
watching being like okay that's the
right amount of grief and maybe they're
internalized senica is going to talk
about memories in a moment as well but
it's more for how I will appear to other
people and this concern that if I don't
show excessive grief then other people
will think I didn't love my friend or my
spouse or my child or or whatever my my
pet or my coworker or something like
that some other relationship so there's
you know is this the case for everybody
probably not but senak is definitely on
to something and so he says
that a lot of people are not just sad
for themselves and he says even in grief
there is competition right so in a way
that makes the grief no longer what it
is you're mixing other elements into it
and senica suggests here's where we get
away from the don't do this advice uh a
positive course that you can take in
this negative experience so he says uh
what then should I forget my friend well
it's not very long you're promising to
remember him if your memory lasts only
as long as your grief so notice it's
possible to have grief to feel that
feeling and that to be something
different from but connected to your
memory of your friend the grief can go
away the memory doesn't have to you can
retain that your entire life and he says
the time is at hand when some chance
thing will brighten your face with a
laugh your pangs will subside every
feeling of loss will be eased the minute
you stop watching yourself your look of
sadness will be gone so you know you
don't have to hold on to your grief
through this attention what are we going
to do let's make the memory of those who
are gone a pleasant memory remember them
in the good parts now this could be
difficult you know friends we typically
want to be with this could also be
applied say to family members imagine
that you have a particularly noxious and
contener and critical family member is
there anything that you can remember
about them that isn't all bad that could
give you a sense of
pleasure um yeah there might be some
mixedness to this and he says that um if
the thought brings torment we don't
willingly return to it we feel a biting
am morsus right and this is a technical
term that the stoics use for what are
sometimes called uh pre passions or pre-
emotion
but it also has this sense of something
that is you know gripping us and doesn't
feel good but he tells us even this can
come to have its own kind of pleasure
and he brings up his friend atilus who
says the memory of friends who have died
gives a pleasure like that of apples now
notice the culinary or
gustatory uh metaphors here or reference
points analogies right we we feel um a a
sense like apples that are both tart and
sweet or like the pleasing acidity of an
old wine and he says after time all that
pains us is extinguished only the
pleasure remains and then he goes on and
says thinking a friend safe and sound is
cakes and honey just all sweetness
remembering those who have gone is
Bittersweet but who would deny that
sharp and even bitter flavors are
sometimes to our
taste so there's three different kinds
of flavors that are being referenced
here and as a bit of a side note we are
accustomed in the present in the west
kind of wrongly to think of there being
four basic flavors and then maybe
there's also a momy sweet salt bitter
and sour so sour and bitter both being
referenced here acidity is sour but
there's also Aeris right rough or uh you
know the sort of uh feeling that you get
from tannin in acorns or wine or things
like that and it's you know when mixed
together with sweetness it actually
enhances the flavor he is suggesting and
I think this is a very interesting idea
here um senica says you can have that so
this mix of pleasant and also unpleasant
but in the circumstances also with its
own kind of pleasure feeling to it but
also you can have sweet and comforting
blonda so blonda is the word that we get
Bland from think of comfort food the
homely simple stuff that we make for
ourselves when we're feeling down when
we want to be cozy this is the the
effect that those kind of memories of
people who we've lost can have for us
according to senaka he says when I had
friends I had them as one who had lose
them now that I have lost them I am as
one who still has them how does he still
have them within memory and this is
where we also need to bring up something
else that senica doesn't reference here
we to some degree have control over what
we do with our faculty of memory a lot
of people don't realize this perhaps
perhaps because they are uh the captives
of memories that just flood them or
things like that with attention with
discipline we can think we can draw out
of memory the things that we want to so
we have a choice about how we create the
the memory image of the friend within us
that we linger
over going on uh another important bit
of advice we should appreciate and enjoy
the friends while we have them right he
says that uh because we cannot be sure
how long we will have our friends let's
eagerly enjoy them now let's consider
how often we've gone on some trip and
left them behind how we failed to see
them even while living in the same place
then we will understand we lost more
time with them while they were alive and
he says some people are careless about
their friends while they have them then
grieve terribly for them while they were
gone this is kind of
foolishness right and this he references
one more time the excessive grief um
they are afraid there may be some doubt
whether they really love these people
and this makes their grief more effusive
they're looking for delayed signs of
their own affection and this is a sort
of shiness again to others who are
actually seeing us or performatively for
the you know images of those others what
will people will say within
ourselves um he also has uh some advice
that you might not like to hear right
you may have gone along with this he
talks about other friends being very
useful or helpful when a friend is lost
they can provide you with consolation
during the grief perhaps they can even
grieve with you because they also lost a
friend in that and he says if we have no
other friends we're doing a worse injury
to ourselves than Fortune has done to us
Fortune took one person from us we are
taking from ourselves every person we
don't make our friend and then he says
anyone who cannot make friends with more
than one person does not love that one
even very much so now he's not talking
about people who are say discriminated
against or never given a chance or you
know become refugees and never have the
opportunity to form attachments to many
people or any other cumstances like that
he's talking about people who live a you
know regular life but don't form
friendships with more than one person
why aren't they forming friendships with
other people why are they putting so to
speak all those eggs in one basket is
that actually good for the friend is do
they want to be you know isolated in
their friendship like that and he says
this is rather imprudent
if someone lost their only tunic where
to weep and wail rather than look about
for something to put over their
shoulders to keep warm wouldn't you
think they were an idiot the one you've
loved has passed away find someone to
love
quem right and this is quoted as sort of
a proverb in the text itself in the
Latin find someone else who you can
bestow that love on notice that he
doesn't say find someone else to love
you find someone else that you can be
loving towards that you can feel
affection towards and here's where he
might seem to be a little bit heartless
he says that um replacing the friend is
better than crying right so you know you
still can cry but it's better to make
some new friends than to Simply say oh
I've I I'll never love anybody again
he also has some really interesting
remarks about the factor of time and
here again senica stresses our agency
time will erode grief as he's pointed
out earlier and he says that we become
tired of grieving but a thoughtful
person should be deeply ashamed to let
that be the means of healing better that
you should abandon your grief then it
should abandon you given that you cannot
continue very long even if you want to
you should stop as soon as you are able
and notice that he's not saying force
yourself to stop he's saying figure out
when you're able to stop grieving and
then choose to stop grieving that is up
to you this emotional state you don't
have to have it be in control of
yourself and he's got some discussion
about how long you should grieve the
only thing from that I think is really
important is that he says our
forefathers established one years the
period of mourning for women not that
they should mourn that long but that
they should not mourn longer than that
so there's a lot of you know traditional
ideas that people have once again we go
to like what you look like in other
people's eyes oh if you really love the
person you'll grieve for a whole year
senica says that's nonsense you can
grieve for a day if you want to and then
be done with it if that's really what
you're able to do don't go any longer
than that cut off point
right then he uh talks about his own
example uh he says you know I've fallen
off the path that I'm sketching for you
so what should we do and here's where it
wraps up let us remember mortality
mortalit in Latin the fact that we're
going to die because we are human beings
let us remember mortality in
ourselves as well as our loved ones I
should have said about serenus he's
younger than I am but what difference
than it make he ought to die after me
but he could die before because I did
not do this Fortune struck me suddenly
and unprepared now I keep in mind not
only that everyone and everything must
die but that they die according to no
determinate law if it can happen at all
it can happen today and we can see this
as actually you know going back to this
appreciating and enjoying our friends
while we can we don't know if they're
going to be taken away from us tonight
tomorrow a week from now a year from now
but they will sooner or later either be
taken from us or we'll be taken from
them so keeping in mind mortality which
may seem to Su a gloomy thought can
actually enhance our capacity to be good
friends so this is a lot of very useful
advice with some stoic practices uh
being suggested to his friend lilius in
a real life situation of facing grief
over the loss of a close
friend